my son will tell me anything he told me
the first time he touched Abu and he
came home he was like hey and I go yeah
and you go go marry and I walk up to him
I go what's up he goes no no no no
outside now I'll tell you what I thought
was happening what I thought was
happening was that point in time in
every man's life where they look at
their father and they think to
themselves oh I could beat the [ __ ] out
of this guy everybody hits me whether
you do it or not you do look at your dad
once you're like I can [ __ ] take this
view down for sure so I thought that was
what was happening so I were walking
outside I was tightening up my shoes I'm
like oh it's [ __ ] Han okay here we go
and and I thought it was gonna he's
stronger than him and faster me I
thought I was gonna have to [ __ ] him
poke him in the neck and be like sorry
dude I didn't know what to do I didn't
know so he goes we get outside he goes
touch the boob man what do you think he
goes definitely gonna try to do that
again but there are some things he tells
me that I don't want to know there's
some things like as a parent there's
some things you want to know you're glad
that your kid is open with you but some
[ __ ] it grosses me out
right so he came home and he's like he
did he did he did
hey oh I gotta ask you a question cuz
you know I'm going out with Ashley you
know I like her a lot that you know
she's super special to me and so I'm
going out with her Friday for the first
time we're gonna be alone alone and some
stuff is gonna happen and I just want to
make sure she still likes me on Saturday
so can I ask you a couple of questions
that might make you a little
uncomfortable
and I said you can't call a friend like
I've done enough raising haven't I I
gotta get into this I know yeah man go
ahead he goes thanks dad okay okay so
first of all dad you know we're gonna be
alone and we're gonna be kissing and my
eyes are gonna be shut right and I go
yeah don't be creepy open I kissy guy
that's the worst it's nothing worse when
you're kissing somebody and you kind of
crack your eye like this and they're
like this and you're like well [ __ ]
tonight tonight I'm gonna die okay
right I don't know I'd be staring at me
from 1/8 of an inch in a way unless
you're gonna kill me later right okay
and I go yeah dude eyes closed he was
okay good question number one answered
and then he goes he goes now dad you
know what I know what I know what to do
here and he told me what his bra move is
and it's terrible but I didn't correct
him because I'm gonna tell you truth
guys I left high school not knowing how
to undo a bra when I was in high school
if I wanted to see boobs my bra move was
this do you know you know what you know
when you put the bra on top of the
titties and it just
it just kind of pushes them down a
little bit because every guy in here did
this [ __ ] it you know what I mean even
to this day the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me in my life is
when my mom came home early from work
and found me trying to take her bra off
of my brother I did not live that
[ __ ] thing down for a long time
listen and I'll tell you this is why I
am the way I am I'm gonna tell you what
happened that night this is who raised
me this is why I am the way I am so that
night we're at dinner right my brother
and I are sitting across from each other
and my parents are sitting across from
each other and um my mom is this really
passive-aggressive northeastern Jew and
sitting at the end of the table and she
was like Tommy my dad Tommy the funniest
thing happened today I came home early
to surprise the boys and boy did I ever
I came home and I found Joshua trying to
take my bra off of Jonathon isn't that
funny and this is why I am the way I am
my dad is at the inner table and he cuts
a piece of meeting us how'd he do
[Laughter]
okay so my son right so he goes I know
what to do I know what to do here dad I
know I go okay okay buddy
and then I wish I could write this this
is exactly what he did he starts to walk
his fingers down his stomach and he goes
in then dad and he goes this area here
I'm gonna give you his quote because I
couldn't have written it any better okay
because this area here this this is
where I hear things get a little tricky
and I said yeah you're right it does get
a little tricky and he goes cuz if my
eyes are closed and the lights are out I
can't see anything so how like dad how
do you will I just need to know like
when you like when you do it how do you
oh and all the time you saying this I
was like man I wish I was high for this
conversation
I can should be so high right now but
he's like hi dad how do you okay I'm
gonna start over dad okay okay
kissing eyes-closed boobs like them take
a walk down to tricky town and here we
are
so dad what I need to know from you is
when you're in this area howdy how do
you dad how dad how do you I'm just
gonna say it dad okay dad dad how do you
touch a woman's banana how do you do
that
and I was like you want to know how I
heard you want to know how I took I
don't know it's grossing me out dude I
can't talk to you about it google it I'm
not gonna give you my secrets are you
kidding me I worked hard for those
secrets it's trial they're trial and
error trial and error every man in
America try something in high school it
doesn't work you [ __ ] tried something
else every guy in here stumbled out of
the gate you think I'm gonna kick you to
the finish line
[ __ ] you figured I like the rest of us
then you don't get from apprentice to
sorcerer in one day that's all I'm
saying I'm pretty sure it took Harry
Potter seven movies maybe eight I don't
[ __ ] know look I didn't know anything
the first time I went down a girl's
pants it would have been nice sure would
have been nice if somebody had told me
but nobody ever did the first time I
went down a girl's pants it would have
been nice if somebody told me that the
hole was so far back I was pushing
around here forever I'm like how do you
get in there if I keep tapping on it is
it gonna pop open I mean no wonder they
call the clam I'm hittin the shell right
now
22 Wi-Fi password for this [ __ ]
little pig little pig let me in like I
don't know and then when I finally hit a
hole I thought I'm so far back I'm in
the wrong log
I jumped the vagina and here was the
worst part teenage boys are so bad at
sex when I finally realized that was in
the right place I just left my finger
there like I was taking her temperature
something no movement or anything just
this right here like she was a
Thanksgiving turkey and I was just
waiting for to be done